gross view those freaking pointy dagger
teeth you can tell it's actually just a
camera that's recording in slow motion
that's spinning around them at like 40
miles an hour
creature work is always something that
kind of intimidates me because there's
so many facets that go into it dude
resident evil took the pace from their
playbook how do you think they did this
thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
video stick around so you can find out
how to get 15 off your next recon
purchase hey everybody welcome back to
another exciting spooky episode of
visual effects artists react it's our
special halloween episode it's the one
time of the year that we look at horror
films normally when we react it's
excitement or joy or humor but today
it'll be scary reactions fear like this
like this like
dude cue the shot from anime fidget
spinners
well that was anger
that was okay
tucking your kids don't let your parents
see turn on all the lights in the house
and let's jump right in
[Music]
the house of the dead so this is
directed by the infamous u-bowl
ube
i always thought he was ooey bowl and
this is shortly after the matrix came
out
so there's footage of the game i guess
in here for some reason you know i kind
of admire that honestly it's really
distracting and janky but who cares
but i love these like four man's like
bullet time rigs poor man's bullet time
this is really it
[Laughter]
if you watch that too you can tell it's
actually just a camera that's recording
in slow motion that's spinning around
them at like 40 miles an hour except for
this shot
[Laughter]
what
oh my god i love it it's like boom and
then they move like three inches all
these slow motion shots feel like
they're like all right get in there
action all right you're you're good get
out of here go go go move next person
oh does it flip he flips why did the
zombie flip why did he throw the x and
why did he ever why is he jumping is he
really a zombie oh there's a little bit
of matrix oh more matrix what's going on
oh that's how shotguns were
they're bees
not the bees the bullet time effects i
wouldn't even call that a visual effect
yeah it's all special effects for using
specialized camera rigs
that's a vfx shot the axe was pumped in
there probably because they didn't
really throw an axe that fast at her
wait was that was that just an amputee
or was that like a that looks like
that's a visual effect it is you can
tell that the feathered edge on this
legs don't quite stay in the same spot
they move a little bit this is how sam
and i did visual effects at the same
time like that's basically a shot that i
did yeah in 2003. this movie inspired us
because it let us know as aspiring
filmmakers that we were making stuff
just as good as what you saw on the big
screen
[Laughter]
you guys ever seen cube oh yeah cube's
great cube's a really good example of a
one location film that's really high
concept and makes it feel like it's not
a one location film this is a seriously
good and creative movie i was so blown
away when i saw this
what happened
oh snap
what the heck
dude resident evil took a
page from their playbook i love that
effect how do you think they did this
that's a prosthetic that's not a real
person there yeah yeah look at his eyes
i
find myself agreeing with sam on this
because the next shot is that same
prosthetic the fingers are crazy it
looks like they move yeah having them
move like an inch before they collapse
oh my god it's so brutal it's a really
flawless effect i have a theory that the
audience likes anticipation more than
the payoff i guess the part that makes
it sit on the edge of her seat
what happened and they just hold this
shot and they have this shot here the
blood seeps onto his shirt and then
seeping down his face then finally boom
i feel like the hand shot is the first
payoff shot and this and this are the
second and third payoff shots and the
payoff shots are cool but without that
anticipation all that style the chunking
shots wouldn't really hit quite nearly
as hard as they do curiosity is a super
powerful thing for human beings like you
can really hook them in with that do you
guys want to see a really gross gnarly
scene yeah i mean sure but it's only
going to be on quarterdigital.com
[Music]
i mean listen we've got extended
episodes on the website so check it out
if you want to see this gruesome shot
guys let's take a look at it at what yep
what's it
oh like literally it literally i t
the clown movie this one's for you ren
i'm sorry oh why i missed i didn't read
it i've seen chapter two i've not seen
the second one okay have fun
what's in this fridge
[Music]
oh it's a body oh
okay that's kind of creepy
rolling head it's really solid visual
effects so far yeah like is that hole
shot cg i feel like it's probably a hole
in the floor and he's sticking his head
through yeah it looks like a hole in the
floor kind of gag to me yeah that's real
hair right there that does look real
that's real hair it's dirty matted dusty
hair which is its own thing you know
like we watched godzilla versus kong you
know they're like look we made like wet
hair for him we made the dry hair
version we made the semi like you can
make all that stuff but like that kind
of look i've never seen before yeah you
don't end up with like eight different
styles of hair physics in one like sim
you don't end up with like sweat and
then like fuzz and then curls and then
straight and then strands and then fluff
like you don't get i mean you can
yeah man kinda to a certain a certain
level of interactivity and physics you
can't
oh
it's got literal hands for hands the
tiny hands it's a very creepy touch is
it gonna be a spider
but isn't this all fake in their
imagination and stuff like why are they
afraid
oh god it got him it did get him it got
him gross ew those freaking pointy
dagger teeth a very ineffective spider
monster
you done teed me oh in the head he was
like don't stab my hands please don't
set my hands don't say my hands hulk
thanks that is some incredible cg work
there wasn't a single shot there that
took me out of it it almost makes me
wonder if the whole scene is cg and it's
entirely possible that these backgrounds
are photography plates but boy are they
making it difficult for themselves to
have to then deal with all the shadows
and interactions from those flashlights
there comes a point when it actually
does become more simple to just make the
entire thing cg i can't help but feel
like all the close-ups or all we see is
the ground it's easier just to get a
unified image with all of the baked in
lighting from everything affecting
itself so is that a full cg shot see
that shot right there looks pretty real
to me like look at all the cobwebs but
isn't it funny how we point to cobwebs
and we say there's no way that could be
fake no i'm not saying there's no way
i'm just saying it's like it's pretty
nicely detailed the thing is like when
something's 100 cg it all has to be
placed by hand so meaning everything
ends up with intention and i don't see
anything that's like not intentional
everything feels pretty intentional the
cobwebs are intentional the rafters feel
intentional the textures feel
intentional you know there's nothing
that's just like oops
we accidentally filmed that too
but it could be cg
you look at the little hands like touch
the flakes in the ground which is just
further indications they have a cg floor
i mean that has to be a cg floor at
first i thought oh that could be like a
little puppet thing but then like it
started articulating in a way that i'm
fairly certain is cg that automatically
tells me that the caliber of cg that
they have in this scene alone is already
high enough that it's making me question
what else is not real either you want to
see some more nuts initial effects back
to the same kitchen from the first movie
wait that's the same fridge yeah
this is such a cool effect
looks so good
that looked like a contortionist dude
with like a head replacement
it's a fully cg body with a real head
when his last arm goes over that's the
full body reveal that's my guess you
pretty much nailed it wren so when he
comes out of the fridge he's coming out
of the fridge for real his head was not
upside down actually i believe it's to
the side and so i've just taken that
footage just rotate it even further and
just kind of re-lit it by hand but once
he kind of like starts to turn it
becomes real and they took out his
entire body and the body is cg and you
can kind of tell if you go to the very
next shot when he's all real there is a
bit of like a distinct difference
everything's just like a little crisper
it is more wrinkly and a little more
detailed you know sometimes it's easier
to not have to transition to the real
thing because now you're pointing out
this is when it's real even if you only
subconsciously see it rather than
notice it
time to flow
so in order to make this halloween
episode a little extra special we
reached out to weta digital to see if
they wanted to partake and they actually
hooked us up with a man named sheldon
stopsack who was the visual effects
supervisor in the tomorrow war he wants
to talk about how they made the monsters
dude the creature work in the tomorrow
war is actually pretty great have you
guys seen this movie i have seen this
movie i watched the entire movie oh i
have not i'm curious
oh
scary spooky hole
whoa
so this is the queen white spike you
know like any sort of colony of aliens
you always gotta have a queen these are
aliens yeah they are aliens
the animation is really nice the
creature actually reminds me a lot of
that one creature from love death and
robots remember that like dog fighting
scene but with like alien avatars yeah
it looks like the less shape-shiftery
version of the creatures from edge of
tomorrow creature work is always
something that kind of intimidates me
because there's so many facets that go
into it from the incredibly detailed
model work and the texturing and then of
course all the animation and then the
rendering with creatures like this you
gotta nail that like specular highlight
stuff it's what makes something look
slimy
spooky
my face looks like a skull it does
it looks like a skull all right i want
to see this shot do you guys feel like
this shot
is rough it's coming up here
oh
yeah
so what about that shot looks rough to
you i think they're facing a very
challenging situation here which is real
footage of chris pratt diving in
and then a fully cg alien and they have
one camera move for the alien which is
super dynamic it's pulling back it's you
know the things galloping looks like
it's it's like running at 20 25 miles an
hour yeah something like that and chris
pratt's lingering in the air as the
camera is moving that speed implying
that he's he launched himself at about
25 faster he's actually going faster
than me so he's going
he's flying at 30 miles an hour
he's catching up to the creature
and that is why it looks weird it is a
bit of a two-dimensional
three-dimensional issue also in the
sense that chris pratt when his film
becomes basically a cut out and then you
have a full 3d model and you're trying
to marry the two doesn't the monster
shrink a little too in this one shot
it's like smaller yeah like in the big
fight it's a good like three or four
heads above him and then when he jumps
onto it it's basically his size but that
stuff happens in movies all the time we
usually don't notice it these are all
subconscious things but when you stack
too many subconscious things on it
starts to feel a little weird
that looks great whoa yeah the alien
melting looks awesome
they get away with it because all the
rest of the shots look really good like
their dynamics are great there's this
concept of secondary motion you know
it's the same thing like in that shot
with the full cg characters and lord of
the rings running across the bridge and
they look photo real because they got
the secondary motion of all their capes
and fabrics yeah yeah the secondary
motion of all like the blood and the
goop and the snow and the technicals
that all really goes a long way towards
selling these creatures and making them
feel really complicated and dynamic
hello everyone hello
howdy so what was your responsibility on
the tomorrow war i was the visual
effects supervisor for weta digital and
what was nice about the tomorrow was
that
it's been a show where we've gotten
engaged pretty early you know really
more in the pre-production phase where
you just have a lot of fun just
exploring things weta was sort of the
lead facility and they were lucky enough
to take the lead in a lot of creative
aspects including on the creation of the
white spikes the white spikes are very
very complicated in their motion or at
least they visually appear complicated
you know they have tentacles that are
flailing everywhere their heads are
moving all over the place there's spits
flying everywhere how do you make that
complicated motion for a creature that's
a good question that's where probably
the challenge really kicked in with the
widespread game anyways because the
animation work obviously was such a
broad range from like individual like
hero moments where you just have the
female on their own but then you have
also you know the other end of the
spectrum where you have like you know
thousands of them and you kind of have
to find a little middle ground like how
much can you actually keyframe there and
animate them and how much do you you
know that eventually do like a sort of
massive crowd simulation do and then
also had this sort of middle ground
basically where our motion edit team
kicked in and they utilized basically
like tons of loops and cycles that we
basically created that allowed us to
respond well at scale you know when you
have like hundreds of them and you want
them to be more intricate than you would
normally get from a crowd simulation
when we watch big budget action movies
these days it almost starts to feel like
visual effects just become like
unlimited we've seen character animation
we've seen complex renders we've seen
photorealistic lighting but if you had
to kind of
find an area that you felt we were still
facing technological
limitations in when doing effects like
this what would it have to be i mean
don't get me wrong there's always
technical limitations and we ran into
them just as much but it was more of a
question can we do better here you know
in visual effects we're at the point
right now in particular with creature
work where you know we push the boundary
in the envelope pretty far it's like you
know there there are very very few
limits left yeah yeah
that's not to say that you know the the
quest doesn't really go further again
especially whether it's such a
technological driven company where you
know you look always at the boundaries
to be pushed further and the nuances and
it can be very specific topics and
subjects and you know intricate things
that you may not really notice too much
in the end of the day but they still
advance if you had a bit of advice for
other filmmakers out there wanting to do
creatures
in their pieces
what kind of advice would you give them
comes away to digital
yeah i think i mentioned in the
beginning take your time explore the
character think about what character you
want to have and what role does this
character play in your movie don't
neglect it as for like being a monster
and a beast and you know visual effects
will do it for you in the end of the day
i think it's important to kind of share
a bit of a vision of what your character
wants to be so that really was a pivotal
point in the tomorrow war well sheldon
thank you so much for taking a moment
your morning over in new zealand to hop
online and join us for for this episode
it was really cool hearing you break
down some of the
the approaches you guys took to the
creatures of this film pleasure thank
you very much for having me it's been
fun talking to you guys all right well
hopefully we'll do it again sometime
awesome thank you guys so long sheldon
what's up guys my name's jordan and i'm
here to talk to you about our sponsor
raycon i know a lot of other people have
been on this couch and talked about
recons before but
let me tell you i am here to talk about
their newest release the work earbuds i
build things i get ready for productions
you know so i just stick these little
guys in and i don't have to hear the
world around me i can put on my noise
cancellation and just jam out to my
music while i'm building tables so then
i go out for a coffee break and that's
when i turn on my ambient mode because i
don't want to get hit by a semi truck on
the way to getting coffee
[Laughter]
raycon is co-founded by ray j and also
loved by many celebrities like snoop
dogg and mike tyson if you need a pair
of wireless earbuds to take you from
conference calls to your zoo meetings
raycon's work air buds are a game
changer so raycon now has active noise
cancellation for maximum focus and an
ambient mode for when you need to hear
the world around you raycon's wireless
earbuds offer a 32 hour battery life a
super comfortable fit and a six
microphone system it cuts down on
environmental noise and ensures your
voice is crystal clear on near zoom
calls raycon offers their wireless
earbuds in a range of fun colors and
patterns with a variety of fit options
and no dangly wires or stims not only
are they half the price of other premium
earbud brands but raycon also offers a
45 day free return policy look the work
earbuds are for you click the link below
or go to buyreicon.com corridor crew
works so you can get 15 off your next
raycon purchase you're gonna be able to
hear everything
or nothing if you don't want to there's
literally to die for
seriously
ding dong hi it's me i'm wearing the
costume i'm dressed up like nico from
visual effects artist react do you have
any
tricks or treats from me and then this
is where you go yes i have a treat for
you and you give me a subscribe if
you're not subscribed and if you have a
trick well let us know your favorite vfx
trick that we should react to in a
future episode and i won't shoot you
with a shotgun that's okay
that scene is for subscribers on the
website only oh yeah sorry yeah you guys
subscribe
see you guys for the thanksgiving vfx
react special where you react to this
we will watch bone tomahawk then
the pilgrims yo there's horror movies
there's halloween movies there's
christmas movies where's the love for
thanksgiving movies come on
no
no i don't give thanks for thanksgiving
movies
yep